The moments when the United Kingdom has come together..
...to applaud its care and essential workers...
...will be remembered as an expression of our national spirit;...
...and its symbol will be the rainbows drawn by children.
Across the Commonwealth and around the world,...
...we have seen heartwarming stories of people coming together to help others,...
...be it through delivering food parcels and medicines, checking on neighbors,...
...or converting businesses to help the relief effort.
And though self-isolating may at times be hard,...
...many people of all faiths, and of none,...
...are discovering that it presents an opportunity to slow down,...
...pause and reflect, in prayer or meditation.
It reminds me of the very first broadcast I made, in 1940, helped by my sister.
We, as children, spoke from here at Windsor...
...to children who had been evacuated from their homes and sent away for their own safety.
Today, once again, many will feel a painful sense of separation from their loved ones.
But now, as then, we know, deep down, that it is the right thing to do.
While we have faced challenges before, this one is different.
This time we join with all nations across the globe in a common endeavor,..
...using the great advances of science and our instinctive compassion to heal.
We will succeed - and that success will belong to every one of us.
We should take comfort that while we may have more still to endure, better days will return:..
...we will be with our friends again; we will be with our families again; we will meet again.
But for now, I send my thanks and warmest good wishes to you all.